the father of Peggy Carter's children
has been confirmed and all we can say is
we need a movie featuring them right now
Avengers endgame screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
have gone on record confirming that
Steve Rogers is indeed the daddy of
Peggy's two kids this raises well
several questions but first a little
background Marvel Cinematic Universe
aficionados are well aware that Peggy
Carter one-time agent and eventual
director of shield is the long-lost love
of Captain America's life at the
conclusion of 2011's Captain America the
First Avenger he failed to meet up with
her for a promised dance due to an
unforeseen plunge into an icy ocean and
an even more unforeseen 70-year
hibernation this haunted rogers for
years and he was only given a slight
semblance of closure when he visited a
now elderly Carter in her hospital room
in 2014's Captain America the Winter
Soldier in which it was revealed that
Carter had married and had two children
have lived a life my only regret is that
you didn't it live yours
Carter's death during the events of 2016
s Captain America Civil War shook Rogers
to the core and it seemed as if he were
destined to forever live in the shadow
of what could have been but amazingly
avengers endgame in which the team time
traveled to various points in the MC use
history to collect the Infinity stones
in a bid to reverse the effects of
Thanos his infamous finger snap gave
Rogers the opportunity for a do-over
after the defeat of Thanos and his
armies Rogers was tasked with journeying
back to the points in time from which
the stones were taken in order to ensure
the timelines integrity he did so but in
a shocking twist he then chose to remain
in the past finally getting his dance
with his beloved Peggy and living out
the peaceful existence he so richly
deserved so what's the deal with Peggy's
two kids Markus and McFeely cleared it
up in their sit-down with thr and what
they had to say will Bend your brain in
more
than one first up McFeely confirmed that
the little tykes were fathered by Rogers
when he explained it was always our
intention that he was the father of
those two children there are time travel
loopholes for that now pay close
attention to his phrasing it was always
their intention that Rogers was the
father of Peggy's children and again
these are the guys who wrote Captain
America the Winter Soldier talked about
a long game did they somehow have an
idea that time travel would come into
play in the MCU years down the road how
could they have possibly known that it's
mind-blowing to think of the
conversations that must have taken place
between these two as they crafted winter
soldiers narrative and even more so to
think that apparently some of their
wildest imaginings for where the
infinity saga could one day go
apparently came to fruition Marcus then
chipped in with an offhand remark that
might just mess with your head even more
he revealed it doesn't reduce the idea
that there are two children who have
somewhat super-soldier DNA while this
revelation might cement Steve Rogers
legacy as a super dad amongst the likes
of Clint Barton aka Hawkeye and the late
great Tony Stark it's not the first time
caps fathered a couple kids in the 2008
animated movie next Avengers heroes of
tomorrow Steve's son James Rogers joins
forces with the other Avengers kids to
do battle against Ultron not only that
but the what if comics propose an
alternate reality where Rogers hooks up
with rogue on the patchwork planet
battleworld
founds a colony there and fathers a
daughter named Sarah if you'll excuse us
we've got to go write a detailed pitch
for a TV series chronicling the
adventures of Peggy Carter and Captain
America's super soldier children here's
something we still haven't quite worked
out though the existence of Carter's
children was established years before
the Avengers time-traveling shenanigans
if Rogers weren't destined to go back in
time and stay there would those kids
have had a different father or would
Carter never have had any children at
all try not to think about it too hard
we wouldn't want you breaking your brain
on our account check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit
they'll so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
you